[Musique]
dina gilbert merci de nous accueillir
ici à l'amphithéâtre cogeco à trois
rivières où vous dirigez harmonium
symphonique on vous a vu cette semaine
lors de la première avec serge fiori qui
était ému et vous on a brassé comme ça
serrait dans ses bras
comment ça s'est passé ça doit vraiment
être émouvant pour vous aussi
honnêtement j'ai pas le mot pour décrire
ce qui s'est passé lors de cette
première le parce que c'était touchant
émouvant il y avait tellement de ces
thèmes en groupe comme projet je dois
avouer que j'ai même versé une larme
pendant le concert puis ça m'arrive
vraiment rarement mais j'étais tellement
touchée par cette belle musique le
parrain un bon solo de violoncelle en
imaginant les paroles justement de la
chanson en décidant lumière de vie que
ça m'a vraiment touché de miroir je
trouve vraiment en train de vivre sous
un voile sur sa disciple de des coussins
publics ont sinon au bon accueil en
consentant des années difficiles de
pandémie où on avait pas de public qu'on
ne l'ait pas se partagent le donc ouais
c'était vraiment une mission henry
vraiment les plus mémorables dans le
calme
vous avez 37 ans vous étiez même pas née
lorsque harmonium se séparer 12000
harmonium d'emblée je connaissais
harmonium grâce à une de mes soeurs à la
maison qui écoutait beaucoup de certains
décédés puis je me suis dit que j'étais
fasciné par bixi et plus tard justement
ce moment là je commence à prendre
clairière des années plus tard je
repique est ce fameux solo là
[Applaudissements]
donc j'ai une attelle pour voir diriger
serge été facile c'est comme une souris
70 de ce genre de projet ou est-ce qu'on
se pince ton si si vraiment je vais
vraiment ce privilège
vous avez parlé de votre sort vous êtes
né en beauce d'une famille vraiment de
musiciens à l'âge de 4 ans vous avez
appris à jouer du piano
dirigez votre premier quart à l'âge de
15 ans j'ai musique pour vous c'est
vraiment une vocation c'est un appel ce
matin me paraît pas musicien mais mon
parent il voulait vraiment que ces six
pays jouent de la musique donc les 6 à
la maison du concert faire du piano fait
partie différent car je te la cinquième
donc pour moi c'était juste naturel de
suivi mise en ligne facile donc ce
n'était pas aussi c'est sûr que ce
moment là pour moi c'est qu'en plus une
discipline technique quand j'apprends
qu'il nous dise ah j'avais pas en tant
que genre faire un métier à saint
georges de beauce on n'a pas les
opportunités d'aller voir des concerts
symphoniques on n'a pas cette immersion
l'appui honnêtement la maison on
n'écoutait pas non plus de musique
symphonique ou quoi que ce soit
j'entends des messages répétés leurs
heures de piano par jour sa sonorité à
ce ma compréhension de la musique
classique donc c'était limité au
répertoire depuis un nom d'artiste
c'est au contact des musiciens qu'on
apprend notre métier qu'on fait un autre
mélange en quelque sorte puis je me
trouve vraiment privilégié d'avoir à
chaque fois je t'aime à des défis
toujours un petit peu plus grand petit
peu plus audacieux de sortir un peu
aussi du québec sam permet d'enrichir ma
démarche vous êtes une des rares femmes
chefs d'orchestre dans la planète
musique classique comment briser ce
plafond de verre et les préjugés aussi
parce que c'est un monde d'hommes faut
bien le dire mais je pense que je vois
là dans les dernières années que
vraiment un désir profond des
institutions de changer ça parce que je
vois de plus en plus de place pour les
femmes c'est pas encore tout fait pour
dire que le sait mais il ya des
initiatives qui sont faites
puis je suis vraiment certaine que dans
les 5 10 prochaines années pour que je
laisse faire ils vont un peu plus de
postes importants jeudi que la prochaine
place c'est vraiment cela c'est le point
crucial de wii ont des assistantes des
orchestres et jeunes ont tranquillement
pas vite falloir d'être directrice
musicale mais des points d'importance il
ya des postes importants auprès de leur
caisse prestigieux ses seuls points
majeurs je pense qu'il va faire en sorte
que toutes les distributions se
revitaliser va se renouveler tout va
finalement respectée dans le fond le
fait que vraiment beaucoup de gens qui
s'intéressent à ce métier passionnant
sur facebook vous avez partagé avec vos
admirateurs et admiratrices que vous
était atteinte d'un cancer dans quelle
mesure ça orienter votre carrière
échangez vos plans pour la suite des
choses honnêtement le je me sens assez
bien dans ce sens que je peux encore
avoir certains traitements qui sont à
venir j'ai pu poursuivre mes activités
professionnelles entre l'agent qui
complexe puisque identique on a plus de
contrôle là dessus mais j'ai été assez
chanceux pour certaines choses je pense
que qu'est-ce que ça le changement sam
encore plus mis dans le moment présent
avec d'apprécier chaque jour c'est
certain puis sinon je pense le fait que
comme chef on est tellement habitué des
temps maîtrise de tous les éléments que
là pour une des rares fois de ma vie
j'en avais vraiment pas mais c'est avec
toute l'humilité que je pense que c est
dans ce sens que tu dis après cette voie
chaque chose avec une un indifférent
tu me rends compte encore plus à quel
point la musique était apolitique qui
était à petit pour moi parce que pendant
que je fais mon métier je pense pas à ça
j'ai pas de douleur pour que ce soit je
suis vraiment juste dans le moment de la
musique je chante le fait d'avoir le
partage du public consiste à nous ça
nous donne vraiment beaucoup d'énergie
donc je pense que c'est comme un bon un
bon cycle exporte nos enfants qui fait
en sorte que je tenir josé à chaque
concert ménages il bat remercie vous
[Musique]